bene a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono pochi j
oggi siamo di nuovo su slider di arrivo
ricordate la prima puntata dove sono
morto in un modo atroce dopo essere
arrivato a sette pagine per ora gara un
primo tentativo nel senso che è
praticamente era un po come vedere la
beta non mi ero preparato diciamo a
vincere ma ci stava anche riuscendo
quindi nella puntata di oggi se riesco
magari cerco di arrivare a apprendere
tutte le 88 pagine anche se penso che
sia impossibile
spero che vi ricordiate anche il fatto
che potete prendere lei le insegne tutti
i poster e infilar veli direttamente
nelle mutande perché non so dove si
dimette
però sinceramente non ho ancora capito
che cosa servono prova beh io li prendo
perfetto manca ancora un volantino ok ok
raga possiamo partire volevo dirvi una
cosa dall'ultima volta che ho giocato a
lander di harry vol hanno rilasciato una
patch un aggiornamento che però non ho
la più pallida idea di che cosa sia
andato a cambiare quindi qual cosa sarà
cambiato di sicuro forse non lo so
movimento dello slam non ho idea di che
cosa hanno cambiato però l'aggiornamento
l'hanno fatto quindi qualcosa di nuovo
c'è di sicuro intanto la vedo già
qualcosa
ok molti ragazzi hanno chiesto adesso ne
approfitto per dire queste cose perché
nel primo video mi avete fatto un sacco
di domande
molti mi hanno chiesto di
diciamo di cosa sarebbe cambiato
all'uscita ufficiale del gioco quando
uscirà perché ovviamente questa non è
uscito cioè non questo che vedete non è
il gioco ufficiale ma è la beta
semplicemente che non è neanche una demo
è proprio una beta cioè nel senso
un'anteprima tra virgolette questo è
semplicemente una zona dove potete
prendere le classiche ottopagine cercare
di non farvi scoprire appunto dallo
slang airmen però non è il gioco
ufficiale gioco ufficiale avrà
innanzitutto la modalità storia ma sarà
una modalità storia con i contro maroni
proprio per dirla tutta e quindi sarà
veramente una campagna etica credo che
andrò a fare di sicuro e inoltre ci
saranno più zone dove poter raccogliere
le otto pagine non soltanto questa
questa qua appunto è soltanto una beta e
molti mi hanno chiesto di metterla si
fosse media five o cazzadore dove piano
pianissimo pianissimo e dentro la
macchina che mi spia sto pedofilo dove
ok ok non è non è in macchina merda dove
entrare io in macchine in questo caso ma
non posso dov'è brutto bastardo ti vedo
ok raga è ufficialmente alto 13 metri
devo riuscire a raccogliere le pagine
prima che mi stupì ok devo riuscire a
trovarle prima di tutto non c'è non c'è
perfetto facciamo il giro
quante ma chi siamo che a furia di
parlarne un po dio oddio si può togliere
l'interfaccia non lo sapevo si può
togliere l'interfaccia non lo sapevo già
qualcosa
raga provano andare un attimo così senza
interfaccia giusto prevedere come però
la brutta cosa ragazzi non so dove
porca [ __ ] via via via via via via
via merda merda merda merda merda merda
merda merda merda merda
ok calmi
ok
cazzo via ma perché deve essere così
stalker uragano è no vabbè ma sto
rendere è fatto troppo c'è sembrano
fatti apposta ste scena c'è non lo so
sembra fatto apposta sembra quasi un
film che tra l'altro adesso
volevo dirvi anche questo nel frattempo
dico tutto ok 4 su 8 perfetto ho visto
che sta anche uscendo il film dello
slider quindi non lo so vi aspetto al
cinema andiamo a vederlo tutti insieme
intanto qua tra l'altro c'è un'altra
pagina è ok
comunque adesso aspettato un attimo che
non mi ricordo come cazzo fatto così
perfetto perfetto ho rimesso
l'interfaccia devo riuscire a trovare
l'edificio da qualche parte
intanto ora gallows lander si è
volatilizzato letteralmente non lo vedo
più è dicevo devo trovare l'edificio
quello dov'era andato anche nello scorso
episodio perché lì c'è sicuramente una
pagina dato che c'è una memoria
letteralmente di merda non mi ricordo a
quante pagine sono arrivato ecco
l'edificio ecco lo devo riuscire
soltanto da capire
è la porta dentro
dice dov'è la porta maledetta porta del
cazzo
ok calmi calmissimi tutti che tutti
molto calmi molto calmi tanto non può
entrare alto 14 metri e mezzo
mio dio devo riuscire a trovare le
pagine raga aiuto prima che riesca in
qualche modo ad entrare non so come non
mi interessa devo trovare le pagine
però niente merda la quale ultima volta
la pace non mi ricordo dove
cazzo mi sa che nell'altra stanza o che
devo muovermi promuovere devo muovere
devo muovere il culo
ok via di qua di archi ok non cazzo ok
ma perché c'ero sempre dietro merda devo
soffiarmi il naso
calmi calmi sì l'ho trovata lo trovate
la gala trovata sono sei sono 6 su 8
allora calmi calmissimi non ci posso
credere allora 6 su 8 ce la possiamo
fare basta credere in se stessi io credo
in me stesso
grilli adesso sinceramente non mi
interessano dove cazzo andato
ok penso sia nella stanza di fianco io
me ne vado via dalle palle prima che
inizia a comparire davanti
all'improvviso che è già una macchina
spero ci sia la settima pagina pregasse
se otterrò no no no no no no premia 7
corri corri male no no no no non posso
morire adesso non posso morire adesso
non posso non possono dire adesso se la7
no non posso oggi non morirò raga oggi
vince per poi merda dove cazzo ok mi
calmo calmo stai calmo
tornata mente il personaggio di questo
slider non mangia tanti hamburger come
negli altri svendere può correre senza
rotolare a terra
sfinito dopo due minuti quindi posso
correre però non so dove cazzo andare
questa è la cosa frutta non vorrei
trovarmi lo dietro poi calibro
sono ancora vivo sono ancora vivo sono
ancora non mi ha preso non mi ha preso
ok ok sono riuscita a salvarmi non so
come perché mi sono preso un infarto
assurdo pensavo sinceramente pensavo di
morire ma sono riuscito a riprendere i
controlli in tempo prima che potesse
prendermi ok sono sempre a 7 raga non ho
perso
non ci posso credere allora allora se
manca l'ottava devo prendere
assolutamente l'ottava pagina da qualche
parte ci deve essere per forza
ok allora allora tranquilli tranquilli
sono ancora vivo sono sarà ancora arrivo
per poco però se non trovo sto cazzo di
pagine non la trovo devo cosa mi manca
che sto girando da un'ora dove devo
prenderla stanno le detta pagina 9
ditemi dove ok ok ok la canoa lotto
la canoa l'ho presa prima merda l'ho già
presa la canola ci sono arrivato di là
quindi niente
raga non posso perdere adesso vipre vi
prego non fatemi se battete tutti le
mani forte forte fa vige riesce a
vincere
novi sicuro vi giuro che se perdo lancio
il mouse veramente no non posso perdere
adesso non posso
allora quella è la torre la prima che
non c'entra in questo caso c'è un'altra
torre che non trovo crea mai in questa
l'ho presa la pagina se il prezzo sarà
sì sì sì compreso prima e non c'è più e
va bene e va bene va bene va bene va
bene va bene va bene va bene va bene va
bene va bene casa
no
ok
ok ok basta mi arrendo se non la trovo
adesso mi arrendo
raga c'è un camion ma non c'è se la sono
dimenticata sta merda in pagina
nell'aggiornamento se la sono
dimenticata nell'aggiornamento non c'era
sì sì sì era sul camion era sul camion
era sul camion sul camion soca perché
trojan o no no no no no no no no vabbè
lasciamo perdere che è meglio c'è ma io
posso mai perdere ad un gioco che è
stato creato da thomas cui n ma che
cazzo
va bene la faccia niente basta basta
basta basta non e non ne voglio più
sentir parlare basta ho raccolto da otto
pagine che sia finito così va beh non mi
interessa non mi interessa il gioco
comunque uscire al 26 marzo mi pare mi
pare di aver letto 26 omaggio marzo nome
mi pare marzo e quando uscirà sarò
contento di fare la storia che spero che
finisca meglio di questa maledettissima
beta però nel frattempo non penso che lo
giocherò più anche perché l'ho finito
comunque raga il video direi che può
finire qui
se il video vi è piaciuto come al solito
lasciato un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook che come ogni video
trovate nella descrizione se non siete
ancora iscritti iscrivetevi noi ci
vediamo un prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]